ما العلاقه بين الكبسه وكره القدم العلاقه
تاتينا من المعلومات التي زودنا بها ليث
بزاري من الدوحه وهي ان المنتخب المكسيكي
طلب تناول الكبسه السعوديه قبل المباراه
المرتقبه اليوم طبعا الفكاهه السعوديه
ساره الاعتبار ذلك مؤشر جيد لان دسامه
الكبسه كفيله بالحد من اداء المكسيكيه وفي
كل الاحوال بالعزيمه والروح والاصرار
سيدخل لاعب المنتخب السعودي لقاء نظرائه
من المكسيكيين في المباراه الحاسمه هذه
الليله والاخضر عينه على التاهل لدوري 16
اذا سلح الاخضر بعامل الدعم الكبير من
جماهيره التي تتوفى الى ستاند سيل فيما قد
يكون التعادل كافيا للاخضر ايضا شرطي فوز
الارجنتين او بولندا بنتيجه نتيجه
[موسيقى]
اول شيء باذن الله ان شاء الله المنتخب ان
شاء الله باذن الله لو واحد صفر اثنين صفر
اثنين واحد اهم شيء نعمل الدوري 16 باذن
الله المباراه ان شاء الله هذه باذن الله
ان شاء الله نفوز بهدف او هدفين ويتاهل
الدوره الثانيه
محمد رمضان
واحد ان شاء الله باذن الله وان شاء الله
نتبعها ان شاء الله مع الاهل ان شاء الله
السعوديه تفوز 2-0 السعوديه السعوديه لانت
تسقط ان شاء الله تاخذ كاس العالم لهذا
اليوم اتوقع 2-0 للسعودين ان شاء الله